welcome to this video playing condo oh I
wanted to play you five actually okay
Miami good let's go to the zillion many
possible openings yeah okay so at least
i got the bishop pair if five is
surprising surprising idea ok so my
general plan here is to going to try to
play on the long diagonal f6 takes pawn
takes rook g8 try to use my matt bishop
pair king edge 8 is just preparing this
movement is just taking it giving me the
g file ok
yeah it's not like not like I'm meeting
him directly but it should be should be
okay what kind of and I can take the
fall right Knight takes rook g2 this is
somehow not winning or what can go to f1
yeah ok ok then that's not working let's
let's reroute then yeah he's simply
dashing out move after move after move
after move must be really simple this
game please think this is a fairly
complicated position but ok let's see
Bishop d3 probably or will he try to
snatch this pawn with Bishop c7 know is
actually playing a defensive move ok I'm
going to put this on the ideal square
and go go from there make sure that this
is never hanging and then we'll see what
to do next rook c8 maybe not ideal but
let's just play a bit quicker
before I expect it but I can maybe just
take a 20 k is giving up the exchange
yeah this is kind of wrecked pawn
structure positions are not so easy to
play but my rooks are active and he
really doesn't have any concrete threads
at all check and it looks fairly okay
okay is trying to enter with the Queen
somehow just keep stuff covered go from
there what what can I do here act in
active terms Roxy to Brooks it to
Queenie to this kind of thing
just want to make the rookin movable
let's say if that's a word so that Queen
okay took with the Queen so egg and
didn't need to do that but it's not bad
King is a bit better here than on a jade
so maybe make sure that g4 is not
hitting that much then try from there
how do you win that it's not so easy I
think now I should attain really
activate the rook threaten rook f3m this
this is a pimp this would be a good way
to give the exchange back for the
default port and wrecked king structure
king saud structure okay so I'm keeping
this pawn attacked and I have threatened
to take I'm going to take him
indefinitely
now that that looks good now I f3 hangs
with a big check and here this should be
good right Bishop age six is no problem
i'm having the Queen covered and f3
Hanks and the bishop is some pinned ya
that should be good cannot really defend
our free
no move right Queen a form from Queen D
7 is this is this a move now maybe I
shouldn't take take the bishop then
check yep Tiki what chick cannot be bad
okay check on a tool king of 193 check
check it looks good check one of the
maids I will play Queenie to mate or
queen age one wait white resigns yeah
okay and we win for a change yeah I mean
this was a weird decision if I've that
it's kind of kind of surprising that he
basically opens up the long diagonal for
me I can also play d 5 but I was
thinking that I should just put it on b7
and then try to check the center with f6
not the only only plan but to put an
interesting one that's that farm and
before I found very surprising that
especially so so quickly because it gets
kind of critical yeah this is a very
strong diagonal and he has to I think
yeah find some kind of defensive set up
after this Black is just in very good
shape with this long diagonal and
blocked iqp this is probably not a good
idea of doing here and if he dares to
take it I always have this option to get
to g2 yeah no I just wanted you to keep
things keep things blocked yeah and I
think this is just not sufficient
chatting trade stuff and I have
everything neatly under control this
those two pieces are nicely controlled
by the f6 point he has nothing to attack
a really one problem is that the dark
squared Bishop EF form why does a a
little bit
a bit out of play as it cannot attack
any of the light squared pieces and
everything is on light squares almost in
my end so it's kind of pointing into
into nothing yet he has spotted the idea
with with the exchange sec which is
pretty pretty decisive yeah okay there
was an ok game alright thanks for
watching